i think i should probably explain some
things about this that
were not put into the public domain uh
at the time in the rose garden
because that whole episode was um
definitely
a major disaster for the government and
for
and for the covert policy so i'll i'll
explain something about it
and then uh and why we got things so
wrong
in the autumn 2019 i had to move out of
my house because of
security threats for about six weeks
on the 28th of february when i was
dealing with the covet problem
on the friday night i was down at
westminster and my wife called saying
there's a gang of people outside saying
they're going to break into the house
and kill everybody inside
she was alone at the house at the time
with our then three-year-old
after that i spoke to the pm and the um
and the deputy captain's cabin secretary
helen mcnamara about the situation and
it was suggested that possibly
i either move in to move my family into
a government
accommodation or move them off to family
on the 22nd of march the story happened
which the
um the lady mentioned earlier about that
fake quote from me basically implying
that i was happy for everyone to die
which led to further problems after that
weekend i then said to my wife
right we've been discussing it for for a
month we've got to get out of here on
friday
so before the whole thing happened with
the prime minister being sick
my wife calling up on the friday and
everything else it had already been
decided that i was going to move my
family out of
london regardless of the covert rules
that was discussed with people in the
cabinet office
and with the private office now
what happened is
because of this we kept the whole thing
very quiet
almost nobody in number 10 knew about it
for obvious reasons because i didn't
want the same problems to pop up at my
parents house
up in durham when the story then came
out
the prime minister and i agreed when the
first story came out about me
much of the story was completely wrong
it suggested that the police had spoken
to me about my behavior because the
lockdown rules and whatnot which was
completely false
the police had only spoken to me about
security issues but the media presented
it
as if i'd been taught to by the police
for breaking lockdown rules
the whole story was crazy the prime
minister and i agreed that because of
the security things
we would basically just stonewall the
story and not say anything about it
and you know i was extremely mindful of
the problem that when you talk about
these things you cause more trouble
for yourself and i'd already put my wife
and child in the fire line on it
so i said i'm not talking about this we
should shut them out about it
and the media stories are all basically
loads of it is wrong and ignore it prime
minister agreed
then on the monday he was under so much
political pressure and media pressure
that he said
this line won't hold we're going to have
to do something about it now at this
point i made
just a terrible terrible
terrible mistake which i'm extremely
sorry about
what i should have done in retrospect is
i should have called my wife and said
listen you and um
you and our boy are gonna have to get
out of london again i'm gonna have to
just explain the truth about this whole
thing get out of london
we'll hold the press conference instead
of that
we had kind of chaotic situation in
number 10 where the prime minister said
we're gonna have to do something you're
gonna have to explain something and i
said i'm not explaining these security
things
otherwise i can have everyone mobs back
outside my house
so i ended up giving the whole rose
garden thing where what i said was true
but we left out the kind of crucial part
of the
part of it all and it just the whole
thing was a complete disaster
and the truth is and then it undermined
public confidence in
in the whole thing the truth is if i
just
when the prime minister said on the
monday we can't hold this line we're
gonna have to explain things
if i just basically sent my family back
out of london
i said here's the truth to the to the
public i think people would have
understood the situation
and it was a terrible misjudgment not to
not to do that so i take you know the
prime minister got that wrong
i got that wrong we both made a terrible
horlicks of it in in a very odd
circumstance on the monday
so that hopefully explains that
situation and
um and makes clear that i know i know
that
my misjudgment on it caused huge trouble
and i deeply apologize for it